da bilde dabei das ist der typ von star
wars und sie sagt der weide
hallo mein name ist luca und ich mache
heute etwas was ich schon sehr sehr
lange nicht mehr gemacht habe es ist
schon mehrere jahre her dass ich das sie
zum erster und damit auch zum letzten
mal gemacht habe
das video kann bei euch unglaublich gut
an das hat jetzt mehrere millionen
aufrufe und leute es handelt sich darum
dass ich heute wieder mit viel reden
werde
ich werde das heutige video und drei
kategorien aufteilen
das heißt ich werde zuerst einmal so
also ich mit siri einfach nur reden dann
als zweite kategorie habe ich euch bei
twitter gefragt und ihr habt mir mehrere
fragen angetreten die ich sierig stellen
soll und zu guter letzt werde ich dann
im video noch einmal auf eine website
gehen und einfach mal schauen was du die
beliebtesten beziehungsweise lustigsten
sachen sind die siri antworten kann bei
bestimmten fragen aber ich würde sagen
wir fackeln gar nicht mehr lange
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir halten hier erstmal den home button
gedrückt und sagen hey sagt er
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
richtig verstanden habe
warum halte ich den home button schon
gedrückt wenn ich doch rede hey siri wie
geht's dir mal schauen was sie darauf
antwortet auch jetzt ist das da schon
wieder einfach weg der scheiße
hervorragend luca also ich hab gesagt
hey wie gehts dir was schauen was sie
darauf antwortet nachricht ist dass da
schon wieder einfach mit der scheiße und
die antwort von ihr ist habt ihr schon
gehört hervorragend
wer kennt es nicht
seit hervorragend so was wie wie geht es
dir zeit habe ich gc
alter wie schnell antwortet die der
mittlerweile was machst du gerade so die
sie weiß wie man klicks auf youtube
macht ich habe gerade voll gespuckt
alter meine ganzen kissen sind jetzt
falls ihr euch fragt welcher kirche
nicht meint ich habe hier eine riesige
kissen land den yuan um was hast du
heute noch so vorsieht
er kocht gerade passt da für mich leider
reicht nicht dass ich keine weiteren
produkte und eigentlich auch gar kein
essen zu wenig sie wird nun antwortest
du so aufwühlt und korrekt und schnell
ja ich ja du siri ja seit wann
beantwortete die frage
k
leute ich weiß nicht wann das so ist
also ich meine das exklusive video was
hochgeladen habe kam halt mega gut bei
euch an und das ist mir irgendwie heute
erst aufgefallen deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht ich mach es einfach nochmal und
ihnen meinen das video was ich dabei
kursieren gemacht deshalb wirklich zwei
jahre her und da hat es vor lange dauert
und sie musste erst mal überlegen aber
jetzt wenn ihr wollt dass ich hier raus
vielleicht eine serie machen und ab und
zu immer mal öfters mit silas
manschetten leiter und weil ich weiß
nicht was ist denn realistisch
das sind mache ich das wie ist das
wetter heute siri regen wie benötige ich
heute einen regenschirm ja es wird ja
heute etwas regen das sind zu dieser
standard fragen die man sich eigentlich
immer stellt hey du liebst du mich
besuchen
du bist ganz schön frech geworden jury
weißt du dass weil du mir die ganze zeit
blöde sachen sagt woran merke ich ob er
interessiert ist wie [ __ ] sagt muss
zahlen
dank siri danke dass du das im internet
nachgeschaut was für mich findest du
mich eigentlich könnte es gar nicht sein
wieso sind wir nicht beide super ok
interessante frage im kopf
warum nennst du mich dummkopf ich habe
das hier im internet gefahren
warum siehst du das nicht dass ich dich
liebe also in dem letzten serie videos
hochgeladen habe hat mich siri auch
schon dummkopf genannt ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt warum hast du mich
eigentlich das ist das resultat
warum habe ich eigentlich hunde wollt
ihr mich komplett verarschen
wir sind jetzt im zweiten teil des
videos angekommen das heißt ich nehme
jetzt ein paar von euren mir
zugesendeten tweets die in ihren ställen
soll und werde dass siri stellen ja das
klingt logisch luca halt einfach deine
fresse ok danke magst du pizza antwort
ist eigentlich klar jeder mal pizza aber
trotzdem magst du pizza das rechte ich
lieber nichts sagen und kopf
wieso möchtest du das nicht sagen das
richtig
die pinguine knie haben schildkröten
ellbogen wir fangen erst mal an mit der
frage also haben pinguine knie riskante
deiner liste mit weltzeit ohren nicht
anzeigt
erfolg haben schildkröten ellenbogen ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe
supergut hat wieder auf jeden fall der
klasse geklappt warum habe ich keine
freunde warum habe ich keine freunde
die sind doch befreundet den kopf
ich hasse dieses ding
so übrigens hier dieses pop schock damit
halte ich die ganze zeit ein handy fest
mega cool wie gehabt gibt zu kaufen im
geschäft denken krebse dass fische
fliegen können denken krebse der fische
fliegen können serie ich weiß nicht was
ich darauf antworten also ich hab euch
hab wirklich gesagt hey du mir mal
fragen was ist ihre stellen soll das
vielleicht lustig ist und dann bisher
hat sie nichts verstanden
einmal hat sie mir gesagt dass irgendwas
mit einer weltzeituhr als antwort auf
pinguine und siri welcher ist der beste
job der welt siri welcher ist der beste
job der welt alles klar
eine absuche hat folgendes ergibt bester
rotwein der welt im onlineshop bei
caprio es war richtig geil gewesen wenn
jetzt luca shop.de gekommen wäre warum
ist die banane krumm serie ich habe eine
frage warum ist die banane krumm
da
den grünen große maßen den raum oder ist
das alles banane
das hat mich jetzt eigentlich nicht
weitergebracht
wir sind jetzt hier auch schon beim
dritten teil angekommen und zwar habe
ich einfach mal eine website aufgerufen
die gedacht hat ja wenn du das wie
stellst kommt eine lustige antwort oder
darauf weist sie auf jeden fall eine
antwort und hat irgendwas lustiges zu
sagen das heißt ich würde sagen wir
fangen heute damit der erste sache und
zwar sondern siri fragen wie findest du
pokémon go
nein nicht nennen wie findest du auch
jetzt hat die dann wieder falsch
verstanden wie findest du pokémon go ich
weiß nicht und die als virtuelle
assistenten über die jagd nach katar sie
lesen in der künstlichen realität
fachsimpeln sollen
stimmt eigentlich sehr ich es ja selber
so ein virtueller assistent als nächste
sache soll man sagen genug ich bin dein
vater jetzt kommt irgendwas mit der
deutschen seite
nicht dass weiter ich saß da weder dabei
das ist der typ von star wars und sie
sagte weiter ich bin müde
das ist nichts gefährliches
ich bin nicht sicher hast du gesagt hast
im internet steht man soll gehen und sie
antwortet dann irgendwie sowas mit
umwegen gehen was hast du noch mal
gesagt oder irgendwie so button
immer weiter mit der nächsten sache
findest du samsung oder apple besser
magst du samsung etwa nicht so gern wie
apple handys ich persönlich war apple
produkte ganz geraden magst du auch
samsung produkte und dazu habe ich keine
meinung ist das iphone oder das galaxy
handy besser ich bin apple ziemlich frei
im kopf ist so eine berufskrankheit von
mir
der staat hat auf der webseite ich
sollte einfach mal siri nach samsung
fragen und jetzt habe ich da einfach mal
ein paar fragen gestellt sagen machen
weiter mit der nächsten sache hier und
jetzt soll ich sie einfach fragen
rate mal
ich weiß nicht ob wir dafür zeit haben
sollte einfach mal raten
tatsächlich brachte doch einfach mal ob
ich das richtig verstanden also hier auf
der website steht der serie auf die
folter spannen will musst du ja einfach
rate mal sagen zugegeben manche die
antworten sind nicht sonderlich kreativ
ich weiß nicht aber dafür zeit haben
manche da hingegen schon und so
antwortete sie zum beispiel sagten
nichts ach ja du hast gerade einen neuen
virtuellen assistenten bekommen das hat
sie bei mir leider nicht geantwortet
also das ist ein bisschen beschissen
jetzt gewesen serie tanz mal bitte für
mich alles klar
ein doktorat folgendes ergibt wo ist
fred wo ist denn fred ok den kopf was
ich gefunden habe
mcw riet den ausrüster und da kann ich
fred finden ich katalanisch fritz gibt
es den weihnachtsmann wirklich im kopf
ich bin überrascht dass du das sagst
ich bin ein großer fan vom
weihnachtsmann ich versteh ich bin ein
großer fan vom weihnachtsmarkt halt
deine fresse dazu gar nicht mehr gerät
mit mopay siri beatbox mal bitte für
mich okay als nächste tag haben wir okay
google verzichten kopf ich dachte mich
zwar nicht statt aber witzig ist das
schon einfach weil es gibt ja dieses
diese google funktionen von wegen
anstatt jury mit ok google und das soll
sie mal sagen also deswegen hat sie sich
ein bisschen schlapp gelacht jetzt eine
sache die wir beim letzten mal auch
schon gefragt haben steht dabei auch die
auf der website wieder und zwar was
jetzt 0 geteilt durch 0 stellt dir vor
du hast nur kekse und verteilt sie
gleichmäßig auf null freunde wie viele
kekse bekommt jeder siehst du das macht
keinen sinn und das krümelmonster ist
traurig weil es keine kekse mehr gibt
und du bist traurig weil du keine
freunde hast dann überholt wie liefen
wir bitte zum abschluss ein gedicht vor
das wasser rauscht das wasser schwoll
ein fischer saß daran sah nach der
andere voll kühl bis ans herz hinein
das reicht jetzt aber mein speicher ist
ausgelastet
doch fakt
an der stelle würde ich jetzt aber auch
das video band meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gern mal
ein like da was hatte ich zu beginn
gesagt wir schaffen was ist denn das war
dann die zeit die wir 17 millionen
bleibt meine damen und herren und lasten
fetten leid dabei 17 millionen likes
gehe ich zur apple fangen an zu arbeiten
und entwickeln ein eigenes siri
hier findet jetzt hier oben ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
mal einen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
dort oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet beim ersten sechs monate
neue sommerkollektionen launischen wird
uns hier unten ist ein anderes video
verlinkt und schreibt jetzt mal die
kommentare siri wenn ihr jetzt noch dran
seid weil ich bin in der rola teil schon
bei 39 minuten